you
so you're going to have the way bra
young men is right and their movements
but you also maybe they don't fulfill
their young or their yen okay you should
fill it in so that you become sensitive
to those energy transformations got this
so as we're going it's Lord that to do
that my body is going to relate to his
money don't want to just swing sticks
that each other so as he goes see how I
move with him I'm not sitting here and
then dodging missed it we are already in
a relationship role and I reach to I
until I you touch his dick I'm not
realistic I reached for it I fill the
center line boom boom
we don't have to go fast
get down to your shoulders as we're
doing that there's a kind of deeper hit
than that and then there's the wood
rolling
so get that keep us out and that would
rolling going ok
we're trying to get the form at get
leveled energy because the superficial
level is like your little kids in your
life this is your fencing okay and so
you have to do the work to get the arms
and you have to understand the human
tendency is to remain at the superficial
and to the under my mind is only good at
one thing at a time okay so you'll get
this kind of staccato and that's exactly
what you're seeing here right in an
Arctic place my turn my turn well what's
happening in between all that you have
no idea you're not responding to it but
the road has kept moving so as we do the
first move I'll see okay and we've come
here he's already shifted do you
understand the fight is already moved
and you cannot go and then you're gonna
move there on that is so we were I throw
my straight punch and you kind of take
the outside line and you come over the
top
oh he's blue he's going to lose every
time okay so we're here goes the
straight punch back the final ready move
so you're going to come outside and over
this off go throw here Oh so once he
moves get them see I did that it shifted
review same thing again whoo I move my
he moves the intercept so here we are I
do the ski movies already moved okay i
know i will not get there on time and do
that you don't move when his Joe is here
you move with his body his got an off
the line of attack so we're going to
slow and watch my center of his Center
okay try to wishes with attention oh I'm
relating to see I moved when he
ok
I have to understand the difference
between a training drill and attacked it
okay and if you're training drill is not
right you're not implementing your life
you're not going to make that jump to
tell okay so for example this is
incorrect ok because to misunderstanding
and drill what you think is happening is
not happening his Joe at this pace and
at that timing is a line that I can use
to get the proper angle for my attack it
is not what I'm walking okay and it's
not there for what I'm going to lift or
manipulate so he is not really as much a
ski as he's an abstraction of a scheme
he's a direction an angle and as time
okay but not all in the same way and not
on all of the same of his being so for
example the when he goes many of you
think that the time the start is here
okay because you related to the line
which is here but you think the line is
the weapon which is why you move the
angle of attack instead the start go is
there
I'm relating to that intention the birth
of intention and I give him as my
partner here's your intention so he has
to now give birth to it and I have to
relate to that I do not relate to the
thing I gave him by which he could give
birth to I do not relate to the joke I
relate to the intention so when we go
I'm moving with that and there's you're
still doing Joe you're blocking the
choke okay and you're stuck on blocking
the joke because your thing that's an
angle of deflection so he that's the
block and stopped on the person who that
stopped them trust me okay and what do
we know is this a good angle of
deflection no because I have the distal
end of the lever so I have a mechanical
advantage which means stay there that if
i push over here then he can be strong
but if i push over here hold it up as
best you can as best you can then he
can't okay we use that and i keel all
the time so I ago that looks like that's
what that's going to do all right let's
just assume somebody is strong enough to
overcome the mechanical advantage of the
distal end of the lever let's go where's
move wait and now let's do the second
loop and the third move so why did that
happen tap it
some weird reason he gives up the center
line while I'm occupying it and that
will happen over and over again there's
no no nada anything is going to work
well that should tell you then I think
that you're not you're not defending the
ski here you understand you're doing a
training drills so when we go what I'm
using is the birth of his intention
which just shows up at the beginning I
relate to that part of the body and then
after that by using soft contact by
using the Joe friction I learn the angle
of attack of Oprah's head so the drill
the tactic that's me keeping the same
Joe geometry right working off the same
attention but I don't have the problems
of the distal end of the lever or
clearing the center so i have to relate
them what do you do unrelated to his
right okay so i have to do my form like
that this is wrong I've moved with his
boy
and I move my weapon so that his weapon
doesn't mean if you now look your body
angle and I did that and we go to the
tactic go back slow I go like this I'm
wasting a lot of motion and I'm going to
have to change angles at some point to
get the downward angle which is the
angle cancellation on his face right
because I'm here and at some point I
going to have to do that so I'm going to
lose momentum and will always force it
impact then the second thing is watch
that angle and watch my center line i
just opened it but the other one is
closed off it goes past my target
because i don't know what he's going to
do you understand so we're here in these
keys and there's a cover movie he's
going and you guys whatever okay so
start just do the drill
don't think that you're fighting by
hitting sticks but you in the drill in
the manifestation of the drill being
fulfilled you're tackling lies so the
drill the tactic
hey here
regain that center line he's going to
hit so but if I'm here right because
I've moved up with him if you watch my
back foot you'll move up with him my
back foot you see when you go staccato
you go like this you're caught over here
okay Annie do you remove now you're here
right or usually you're not there and
you're over here in this joke comes here
you'll have connection so he moved up
the circle my back foot has to move with
he moves so now now we're back in the
same connection to the same Center life
i have already neutralized his strike
because i already addressed and
reconcile his intention but it so he now
goes he's gonna not be able to hit me ok
will you put that foot back where it was
and he will be able to hitch so I'm here
he reminds the film and I let him
because I don't know where he's going
right I don't know if he's going high I
don't know if he's going low so i will
hold the center line until I figure it
out home
to get it out of my shoulders my body
moves don't be here hit it hit go back
and hit it you gotta get it out of your
shoulders it just turned this bush why
comes in same kind of thing like he's
pushing on my hand right this is not
what we're doing he pushes on my hand
you let it go dead so he's pushing on my
joe i left my Joe go dead but my sander
stays alive because I was ultimately
related to him not his Joe so we go I
bring turn it back on as his Joe passes
come back
Wow
but when we have a vengeance
I've idea okay so in his category though
it's going to be a point of articulation
a point I wish to Joe generates a radius
and now its travels along the circle
time when I take an angle deviation I'll
have to move into his own a sanctuary so
that means that I'm going to have my
circle right taking apex of the circle
cross square by connecting those a Texas
right and then shade in a circle and now
those corners of the square are not
shaded in that's where i'm going to move
okay so when i do that second move and I
come over here I have to stay outside
the radius of his weapon if i go here
then here i moved inside the radius of
his way okay and I don't have an angle
of daeviation to be redundant with my
angle of deflection and we've got that
also I moved into the effective range of
his power so even if I wore to deflect
it right is probably going to overpower
my block anyways should thank you go
back
so we have the US so I go one okay there
there is the radius say they're see it
now my goal was to stay outside of it
and regain the center line okay oh but
if I put my right foot where the radius
is the end of it and now step in okay
you're on the center line aren't you
right but you're inside the power art of
the web okay so one my angle deviation
is not redundant with my angle of
deflection I'm all dependent on my angle
but two we're here we're here there's
not much on this make you strong there's
not much on it as I started getting
closer don't let me see and you can go
to the extreme to test page one hundred
percent wrong so the closer that I'm
getting to his hands the closer on
getting to the axis the more powerful
he's getting so if we switch roles okay
so there you are right and now move in
okay would you say that's he moved in
okay
have your jovi they target scoot your
head out of the way step back just leave
that target back do you understand you
guys see where I'm at ok so now that's
where I was but his head is here well
that looked like it was pretty effective
right if you move closer to his hands
where the distal end concept is now
being used against you I know how that
this way I'm going to go close to its
next step ok so as you move up the
radius cannot have your right foot go to
the end of the radius because your left
foot is now going to move inside ok or
you could do this but now you have no
base almost 2 flex your spine to
generate the power ok so you have to
make room for your left foot and it's
going to go out and your left foot has
to go to the end of the radius come back
so we go I see and my left foot goes to
the end of the radius ok all right let's
try see you remember the radius right
little plot points of the jail so he
school I'm fighting right yes ok as he
goes I'm looking at him so now keep that
in mind and remember the clock arms
radius lysates about there
if I go like this was my Center pointed
at him is it pointing it no it's not all
right so I go like it's 20 to him but
what's the whole know so when you travel
up the radius you just like you have
your your rifle you would have pointed
at him you're not going to move up the
radius like that so if you watch my hips
now you're going to see that on my point
there's actually a hip rotation so I'm
going to be long gate the front of my
pelvis here and this Joe is going to
rotate as I go see I to dot so we go
watch for that movement 10
so I'm looking at him and I was looking
at him the entire time be careful in the
same way that you do radius and then in
the radius that you're not doing a two
dimensional linear pattern what are your
like is it was a second where you want
okay let's go